This is a super interesting story that we've
actually been covering for several months,
there's this guy named Neil Cavuto. He's a host on
Fox News, Fox Business and Neil Cavuto had cancer,
has multiple sclerosis and recently got COVID for
the second time. The second time and he ended up
in the ICU. And the interesting thing about Neil
Cavuto is when he came back from his first bout
with COVID, which was much less serious, he kind
of admonished people in his audience for sending
him messages about how they want him to die. And
he kind of confronted his own audience and said,
Go and get the vaccine. He now has again come back
and called out his own audience after he ended up
very seriously ill with COVID. And he says, I was
told had I not been vaccinated, I wouldn't even
be here. I'm just telling it to you the way
it is and the fact that this guy constantly
has to call out his own audience for their false
beliefs is really something but good for him for
doing it. Check out what he had to say yesterday.
Speaker 3: So I wasn't really hiding anything. I
just felt that I wasn't the story. The stories
on this show were in are the story. It's about
you. It's not about me. Just like this show,
my opinions don't matter. You matter. The news
matters. But this did drag on a long time for me.
So you really do deserve an explanation from me.
And here goes. I did get COVID again, but a far,
far more serious strain. What doctors call COVID
pneumonia. It landed me in intensive care for
quite a while, and it really was touch and go.
Some of you wanted to put me out of my
misery. Darn near. Got what you wish for?
So sorry to disappoint you. But no, the
vaccine didn't cause that. That grassy knoll
theory has come up a lot. My very compromised
immune system did because I've had cancer,
and right now I have multiple sclerosis. I
am among the vulnerable three percenters or
some of the population that cannot sustain the
full benefits of the vaccine. In other words,
it simply doesn't last. But let me be clear,
doctors say, had I not been vaccinated at all,
I wouldn't be here. It provided some defense,
but that is still better than no defense.
Maybe not great comfort for some of you, and
frankly, not great comfort for me, either.
This was scary. How scary I'm talking Ponderosa
suddenly out of the prime rib in the middle of the
buffet line. Scary. That's how scared. No matter.
I'm not here to debate vaccinations for you,
just to offer an explanation for me. I told you
that I didn't want to become the story, but for
many of you, I did. So now you know the story.
Time to get back to far more important matters.
Speaker 1: The degree. I mean, listen, if
your audience is so unhinged and weaponized
that this regularly, you have to explain to them
simple realities about vaccination and COVID.
Maybe this isn't the right audience for you.
And of course, I'm not like a big defender
of Neil Cavuto, but for the most part,
I find his political views just kind of
mildly disgusting in the sense of like, yeah,
he's he's just kind of like a center right,
primarily economic right winger. And I don't
agree with him on much, but his audience seems
absolutely horrible. And of course, we know that
they are. Just think back a few months ago when
he had covered the first time, maybe this was
more like, I guess this was about six months ago.
He shared some of the emails he
got from people wishing him dead.
Speaker 3: And we got T.J., who also emails. It's
clear you've lost some weight with all this stuff.
Good for you, but I'm not happy with less of you.
I want none of you. I want you gone dead. Kaput,
finished. Get it now. Take your tube device
deep. Six It and you. That's a rather harsh Neil.
So but I figured I'd relate it to The Sopranos
prequel. Yes, it does sound kind of like that. OK,
now we got Vince on Vince tweets. Hey guys, I
bought a new car after being told it was the best.
Then I blew up after I left the car lot. So now
I'm begging everyone to please buy the same car.
Sorry, I was just pretending to be Neil Cavuto,
which I think is being a little sarcastic there
in that last week. Yes, a little bit. A little
bit better. So, OK, but I know you love that.
Here's another tweet PolitiFact PolitiFact biased.
Neil Cavuto has been fully vaccinated for months
and has been a vocal advocate about the safety and
efficacy of COVID vaccines publicly and repeated
repeatedly on air. This is not a new position for
him, which is true. Neal is not a new position,
and that's kind of what we were stressing in
all seriousness. Look, this is something for
the very beginning. I've been saying that
I think the better part of Valor is if you
haven't been vaccinated, it might be a good idea
for you to get vaccinated. I understand those for
religious personal reasons don't want it, but
I understand all. So the numbers that the more
you do get vaccinated, the the bigger the drop
in cases. Absolutely, yeah. Didn't call on all
receptive, you know, certainly that I got another
one for you. From Agnes aspiring to aspire tweets,
Cavuto is the tigger of talking heads. Say, OK,
Speaker 1: anyway, I think you guys get it,
and this has been something he's
been dealing with for a while.
And this was his and again, we covered this
at the time. He's been doing this for months,
and his audience just doesn't seem to get it. Here
he is, begging people think about someone other
than yourself when it comes to the vaccine.
Speaker 3: We lost five million globally to
this. We've lost nearly 800000 in the
US. Take the political speaking points
and toss them. For now, I'm begging you, toss them
and think of what's good not only for yourself,
but for those around you. If you don't want
to do it for yourself, if you think it's a
pain in the ass, I get that right. But think
of others around you. I daresay people who
experience this and seen loved ones who've been
affected by this or have never died from this,
are not judging the wisdom of Band-Aids. They're
wishing they got vaccinated and they didn't.
Speaker 1: Listen, I sometimes have disagreements
with like a sliver of my audience. There are
people who disagree with me on my take on Russia,
Ukraine. There are people who disagree with me
on my take on hate crime enhancements, or
Cuba or Venezuela or crypto or, you know,
whatever, whatever. But if the majority of my
audience seemed to be at odds with the fact that
I think the vaccines protect you from dying
from COVID, which is what the science shows,
I accept. Rather, I accept that I think or
believe I would be reconsidering what the hell
I'm doing now. My situation is different because
I am my own platform in the sense that Cavuto
has taken his views and he works at Fox and he has
the Fox audience. OK, if you went somewhere else,
he would have a different audience. Presumably,
I don't know how many people are super loyal
to Cavuto, but he seems sort of uninspiring in
that way. It's not the same for someone like me
in the sense that we're on platforms where you
can just watch somebody else. And so I don't
think I would end up in a situation where that
were such a significant portion of my audience
disagrees with me about something so fundamental.
But these are people where nothing will change
their mind at this point in time. And we know the
numbers, we know the data, we know everything.
Although I don't agree with Neil Cavuto
politically, I'm glad he didn't die.
I'm glad he was vaccinated, and I see no
reason to question what the doctors told him,
which is at the level of severity that you
got sick, this time in the ICU. If you were
not fully vaccinated, it's likely that you
would have died. That seems reasonable to me.
And whether this will change anybody's mind in
Cavuto's audience, I have absolutely no idea